a 24 year old called Corporal Chief
tackling a fire in sandini and died
tackling that fire in that underground
car park that announced by Gerald Damon
and the interior
Minister and that I think will shock a
lot of people I think there has been a
kind of fear that emergency services who
are attending to all of this disorder
all of these fires of which there have
been
hundreds thousands over the course of
the past few days that have been put in
Peril and that something like this could
happen because this follows on uh that
that being an inadvertent it would seem
that somebody attending through uh to a
fire of course the previous day we had
the very deliberate targeting attack on
the house of uh the mayor of another
Parisian suburb so although these
tentacles of disorder are spreading
around France and are causing these
isolated very terrible incidents I think
there is a broader picture that people
in this country will cling to which is
that the number of arrests has gone down
157 is the latest figure that was
announced this morning and as president
macron will meet 200 Mayors later on
today he chaired a meeting of ministers
last night the hope is that we are now
on the downward curve after best part of
a week of at times uncontrolled violence
in this country